the clowning was relaxation for me i
enjoyed entertaining kids
like some people are you know they
they unwind in different ways either
either going out drinking or that i
could put on clown makeup and i was
relaxed
and i enjoyed doing it i was uh twice
it was only twice a month that i did it
yeah this was not using for a lure to to
draw kids to you as uh no we would visit
uh
different hospitals and entertain the
children there
and we didn't entertain them with
handcuffs or anything like that all we
used was
uh balloon animals and small toys and
stuff like that but we also did parades
and in the summertime like on fourth of
july i used to be in
four parades in one day i've always told
people
when i got into clown makeup i regressed
into childhood it was fun being a clown
because you could
you could be yourself or just let
yourself go and act a fool
you could be slapstick and funny and
have a good time
that's why i always enjoyed clowning
clowning has taken a bad
name because of what they've used in my
[Music]
case
you